yeah walk out to this video playing a
jimmy joe and played the sicilian for a
while i just noticed and he's playing
the smith [ __ ] hmm yeah I don't really
like to take it yeah I always played
that but it's not really so bright it's
simply I'm kind of a more oxy point
where black is sound having one piece to
me too many on the board yeah black and
the maracas CM really would like to oh
this does chance I'll take not that it
is particularly clear but at least I
have some idea how to ever do something
in this game um and I get rid of one one
minor piece I kept 25 now I can take t3
okay if I've is not not a big problem
okay what I wanted to say is before Wow
there may be and now if five years it's
not not so bad interesting decision
yeah go to bed I got a weak King
position no doubt about that probably I
need to do this at some point don't like
this position Bishop c5 was a wasn't
probably a good move now maybe I must
avoid it then okay but I don't want to
paint it all black iam it's not though
it's not like I should should lose or
something instantly yeah how to play
this nice is quite quick on the default
I need to yeah I need you okay I need to
quickly really quickly get on the
default if he combines this Bishop g5
idea mmm look here kawin d5 or maybe now
I can do that yeah this wasn't possible
before because of the Queen honey too
but this this isn't so terrible now I
hope I probably lose the c5 pawn but
this isn't the end of the world
yeah Queens off would be helpful
immensely 95 95 is not really not really
great
yeah but I don't know what else to play
at least it looks like some
simplification
yeah this is debatable I know he can
take with the pond but then you didn't
do it it wasn't-it wasn't clear that
taken with the pawn really was the best
I wanted to have some kind of activity
with e4 or now Queen f4
yeah maybe you can just enter the
seventh film take him this passive what
a passive game I what if he made some
some really good moves keeping them
keeping the pressure on all the time I
really didn't have much in terms of
activity or anything maybe it's still
all right i mean this is possible i have
some supports that i cannot take as well
oh goody
what is he doing I mean I understand
that he wants to activate the king but
it's not this car not going to just here
now the rook is nice on the
fourth-ranked now this is the cmas plate
was certainly better for white not not
sure now but I don't know I've got two
connected connected Panthers I go check
and drop before it's not to check what
on earth am I talking on c4 I will play
king if oh of course nonsense okay but
it's a no use anyway I need to I need to
move the pawns here
I don't really think that this King
March is so dangerous or I see a
threatening a sort of Perpetual stuff I
don't think so and you have to check the
important check
yes it's really surprising that I'm the
summer want this end game I thought I'm
just hanging on barely here just look at
this quickly I thought I thought I have
decent chances to draw maybe but it's
simply passive you know this route 86
was better keeping the roofs on and this
already I have some counter play but he
can of course easily draw I mean just
like this taking taking stuff even-even
this one now let's its passive but
nothing nothing happening yeah it should
have been the drawer probably or I had
all lost our free if he'd play some
place um ok 6 i'm on i'm still under big
pressure he played this very nicely
Bishop takes see five assists an
interesting idea and then e five Adam
it's sort of oops it highlights those
this those weaknesses you created by the
bishop capture not easy not easy to play
yeah thanks for watching